for the past 22 years our next guest has
been the sheriff in San Miguel County
Colorado bill masters he's also out with
a new book called drug war addiction
good morning thank you for being with us
my pleasure let's get right to the book
in one of your conclusions and that is
that you write the first drug war has
become an obvious addiction it's money
law enforcement agencies are addicted to
the money billions of dollars are spent
in an effort to stop the flow of drugs
into and around this country many
thousands of jobs are tied directly to
drug introduction into interdiction in
some communities have become dependent
on prisons for their economic survival
there is or there's a real law
enforcement industrial complex that's
built around the drug war and it comes
from federal grants that are given out
to to law enforcement agencies it's the
the prison industry the rehabilitation
industry to a certain degree
court-ordered rehabilitation industry
there's a whole gamut of federal and
state programs aimed at fighting drugs
at the expense of other crimes for
instance the year before September 11th
we arrested 750,000 American citizens
for possession of marijuana and only two
terrorists and it seems like we need to
reverse those statistics at least and be
able to say our industrial complex our
law enforcement complex that's that's
devoted to fighting pot smokers should
be changed to another another area so
what's your recommendation my
recommendation is decriminalization to a
certain degree and controlling drugs as
opposed to having the current anarchy
that we have in place right now drugs
are completely out of control and over
the past 30 years it spread from a
relatively minor problem in the inner
cities and some college campuses to
every town village government school in
the nation it's even in our prisons I
was speaking to the department of
corrections director in Colorado a year
ago and he proudly stayed that they
tested all 15 thousand inmates inside
the prison walls of the state of
Colorado correctional facilities and
that only three percent of them tested
positive for drugs are 450 of those
people were actually using drugs inside
the prison walls and it seems like we
can't even control it in that kind of
environment how can we kompas ibly
control it
in our cities and in our schools we need
to develop a new strategy that that
really focuses on the demand as one old
boy told me in call in Colorado he said
said sheriff it seems to me like you're
trying to shove hey into the wrong end
of the horse and it seems like we are
trying to do that instead of dealing
with the demand issue we're dealing with
a supply issue and we have to look in
the future the supply is going to be
endless they knew the way of new drugs
in the future are going to be these
designer drugs that we see more and more
of today largely like the
methamphetamines you can go and buy the
supplies necessary to manufacture them
right there in your local convenience
store bring it home cook it up in your
own kitchen and in eight hours later you
gotta pound and a half of
methamphetamines I don't see any way
that we're going to stop that supply in
the future we need to develop a strategy
that goes toward the demand issue of
this particular problem we're spending
the next 30 minutes taking a closer look
at America's drug policy from the
perspective of Sheriff Bill masters the
numbers will be on your screen can also
email us at journal at c span org why
did you write the book you know I wrote
the book really at the number of
libertarians advocated it that I should
get in and write down my opinions I've
been writing certain articles about the
drug war and and they said you know this
could make a good book and people need
to hear this particular message and so
we sat down and and I started writing
more and more articles and and people
kept calling me every day what did you
write today Sheriff what did you write
today and it was a little difficult for
me I'm not a writer as a profession
obviously and but I finally got through
it and we developed a book if somebody
in telluride colorado possesses cocaine
or deals with drugs do you enforce the
law absolutely i right now that is the
law and we and we are we're going to
continue to enforce that law and and the
pull the laws I've sworn to do that but
we have 30,000 laws on the statutes are
in the books in Colorado and we have to
triage some of them there's 604 traffic
laws alone and you know if you go and
try to enforce every one of those nobody
to drive anywhere so we have to we have
to to triage them to a degree I'll tell
you a few the things that we've done in
our community we've taken our drug
seizure funds for instance then we
guarantee low-interest loans to people
that need drug or out
call rehabilitation and we make them pay
the money back but if they don't have
the funds to go to alcohol or drug rehab
programs we supplied them with that
money will guarantee them the loans and
they'll get a low-interest loan that we
require that they pay back as part of
their treatment that they have to admit
that's their problem not anybody else's
problem and they have to have to be
accountable and responsible for those
particular loans and their addiction but
that's just one way of trying to do
something different with it rather than
impacting our jail system and housing
these people in jail where we're really
they don't get any treatment they just
sit there in jail and I'm very I think
it's very important that we keep jail
separate from treatment that jail is for
punishment and treatment is for when you
have an addiction if you commit a crime
if you're a thief because you're
addicted to drugs I don't care that
you're addicted to drugs i carry you're
a thief and we need to judge people
harshly for their their their aberrant
behavior that endangers others or hurts
their property and and that's what jails
for but if they're addicted to drugs
they should go to rehab as they form a
Republican when and why did you switch
parties to become a libertarian I'll
tell it's kind of kind of a long road
but hey I was dealing with a particular
vicious homicide a young girl been
kidnapped and murdered in a neighboring
County and after two years she was
discipline she disappeared for two years
we found her body remains in my County
and she'd been bound by wire clothesline
it was a particularly terrible homicide
and we developed a suspect was a former
police officer from Miami and we started
tracing his movements with the help of
the ViCAP unit in the Casco unit which
is a child abduction serial killer unit
the FBI and they really helped us in
tracing his movements and the police in
Reno Nevada had him arrested for killing
two women there and they raided his
storage locker and they found inside the
storage locker a bunch of refrigerators
and the guy had drilled air holes in the
refrigerator's he would keep his kidnap
victims alive in these refrigerators in
between their torture session so really
affected me was it was a terrible
terrible murder case and the the FBI
invite all the investigators together to
meet at Quantico Virginia a few miles
from here at their training academy
and we we all got together and I was a
little disappointed when I realized that
the Casco unit the child abduction
serial killer unit it was really just
staffed by a handful of agents and here
was a program that that was designed to
track down every vicious child murderer
in the nation at the type of crime that
drives fear into the hearts of every
parent if their child's missing for even
a moment and but it just had a handful
of agents but meanwhile at the training
academy there were hundreds of new
agents going through their basic
training and their Albrighton good
looking young people all going through
their basic training and so I asked one
the Casco units during a break I wanted
at one of the agents and I said why
maybe when all these FBI agents get
graduate from the Academy we can get
more people assigned to the Casco unit
and he said he kind of rolled his eyes
at me and said sheriff these aren't FBI
agents these are all DEA agents the Drug
Enforcement Administration has taken
over the FBI academy to train more drug
lawyers and I think it really hit me
really hard at that time and I said you
know we've got our priorities all wrong
we have we have invested all this money
and time into in the top stopping maybe
a pot smoker when an intern we have all
these other terrible crimes going on we
have these terrorists running around a
swearing destruction of our country and
even in my own agency we're out worried
about somebody who's uh who's got a
little pot in his basement and playing
video games it doesn't seem to make any
sense to me and even today you read in
the newspaper about the AI NS giving out
visas to these terrorists that hijacked
the plane and they're obviously dead and
and something should have stopped those
visas from being being issued but you
know the AI NS is a law enforcement
agency there's a reason why those
mistakes are being made is because
they're grossly underfunded really at
the expense of going after drug users
when in fact maybe a different system
would cut down the cost and actually be
more effective let's get a call from
Decatur Illinois for sheriff bill
masters of Colorado good morning good
morning my name is David acre and i'm
calling from decatur illinois first
I want to thank you for your efforts in
confronting what I feel is most
devastating social and economic
exploitation of people since the days of
slavery I live in a town here that's not
doing too good very economically but we
just opened a women's prison last year
and ninety percent of the women in this
prison are there on drug-related crimes
sixty percent of those women have
children that are forced to be put in
foster care because their mothers are
imprisoned and my thinking is while
these mothers are in prison these foster
kids are being put in places where
they're not going to get enough love
they would from their mother and as we
know when kids don't get the love and
attention that they need they often
turned up drugs and alcohol so don't you
think that what we're doing is in fact
breeding a whole new generation of
addicts it certainly appears to me that
that's what we're doing and it is really
sad that way now some of those people
are definitely going to be drug abusers
may be hopelessly addicted to drugs but
they need to be in treatment not in the
prison system it's also one of the worst
things about the drug war that I can see
is it depends on who you are as to where
you end up in a in the system some
people that have drug problems end up
having drug rehab centers named for them
other people claim the the governor of
Florida recently stayed that that his
family his daughter's drug arrests was a
private family matter and and of course
it should be but it doesn't matter that
should be a private family matter if you
live in the governor's mansion or a nice
house up on the hill or a trailer park
in the West or a tenement in a large
eastern city everybody should be treated
the same but this disparity in the laws
in the way it's applied causes a it
debases all of our laws and allows
lawlessness to become in place and even
invoke and furthermore it puts a tarnish
and all the law man's badges that it
depends on what class you're in as to
how you're treated in in the drug war
whether you end up in treatment or you
end up in
and that's that's a that's wrong from
the Democrats line ossipee New Hampshire
good morning good morning and I
celebrate so hearing these words I'm an
ex heroin addict myself I did not start
taking heroin because I felt really
great about myself basically it was a
way to do what doctors do when they
prescribe drugs which is make you feel
better and basically self-medicate
you're going to get bashed and cremated
and everybody is who is afraid of the
words you are saying I'm sure we'll call
and take every opportunity to tell you
how wrong you are but what really drugs
are illegal I mean coffee is caffeine is
a drug cigarettes are a drug in the the
foods we eat we have hormones and
antibiotics that we're ingesting those
are drugs that you watched you watch TV
and every other commercial is from a
pharmaceutical company Pfizer Lily take
this drug take that drug you know the
side effects are horrible but if you
have this one little malady this drug
can help depression the pharmaceutical
company you know that industrial complex
you know is advocating drug use for
things that certainly could be through
new proper nutrition and diet and
education eliminated without taking
drugs and it seems to me that the most
fundamental problem that we face in this
country which leads children to be
attracted to drugs is number one the
role models of the adults who are
smoking cigarettes and drinking alcohol
and taking drugs for every malady and
number two the widespread lack of love
and nurturing for some reason babies get
born and they're happy and they're well
adjusted until there until the system
the the parental system which is either
non-existent or there's a single mother
or there's a single parent you know the
problems that attract kids to take drugs
and smoke cigarettes and drink alcohol
start you know very very early in life
Thank You caller well the caller bring
some very interesting points and at
first I was a bit about children and
their role models i think is really
important one to issue it did address so
many people say well what if we
decriminalize marijuana wouldn't that
wouldn't that give a bad message to our
children but look at the messages
they're getting already I mean what do
you say to your to your daughter when
you're watching TV and
a senator and former Republican
presidential candidate comes on the TV
pushing a recreational sex drug you know
that some people need some men need but
it's also a drug that's grossly abused
in these sex vacation brothels and
Thailand and other countries and it is a
very abuse drug and what do you say to
that to your daughter wait when they go
and say what's the senator trying to
sell is their dad and and why is that on
TV who decides what recreational drugs
are legal and illegal the same thing
goes with the weekly prozac ads that
have LSD inspired colors in them and and
what are they really saying they're
saying you can get by with a little help
from your friends the drug companies and
I think some people need these drugs
there's no doubt about it but but on
other hands some people are are
influenced by those ads and the children
certainly are we also have this the writ
limit that is given to our children
that's twenty five percent of the mail
is going to some during in certain
school districts are being Medicaid
every day on methamphetamines the same
drugs that are gross are highly
addictive and are being abused
throughout our nation and why that's
happening I don't know the the United
States consumes ninety-five percent of
the methamphetamine drug ritalin given
to our children and and why why those
met that many kids need to have a pill
every day to go to school I don't I
don't clearly understand and that's a
very strange message to be giving to our
children one hand here take this pill
every day and another one saying don't
use drugs our guest is the sheriff in
San Miguel County Colorado bill masters
he's also the author of a book called
drug war addiction an email from a
viewer who says do you have any
scientific data on how effective
addiction counseling is in actually
getting people off drugs I'm not sure
that it that addiction counseling is is
particularly effective I mean it
addiction is a medical and spiritual
problem to people and if they're if they
haven't gotten to the point yet where
they're ready to make a decision to quit
drinking to quit using tobacco too quick
using heroin
or marijuana whatever it might be you're
on a very difficult time getting those
people off those drugs even prison
doesn't work as I've stated before John
Hague from Columbus Ohio says even in a
movie like traffic which supposedly
shows us all sides of the drug issue
there is part of the story that is
missing we never see the person that
works hard all day comes home for dinner
helps the kids with their homework puts
them to bed and then smokes a little pot
in the back yard before going to bed he
says they're literally are millions of
Americans some of whom are my good
friends who vote work and pay taxes
while responsibly using drugs I think
one of the biggest fallacies about drug
abuse is that everybody who uses drugs
is some kind of crazy maniac that's
going to go out and commit crimes and
that's just not the case there are large
numbers of people just like this person
describes that use drugs and and don't
go on to harder drugs that aren't some
kind of crazy person but they've made a
decision in their life to say that this
particular drug even though it's illegal
is better for them than drinking a
couple martinis and for some people it
may be I I would hate to go to go and
say I'm going to judge every single
person and their particular drug use to
say what's good and bad we need to
change our ideas and say and put all
these drugs into the same basket and say
every single one of them is going to
affect your mind body and spirit so be
very careful the ones the doctors give
you the marijuana the alcohol the
tobacco all those drugs can be very can
affect you in different ways and each
person will be affected differently as
well have you ever used drugs yes I have
I used marijuana a couple times when I
was a kid and didn't I was more of a too
much of a conservative kid I guess to
keep doing it or something so it never
affected me that great Valparaiso
Indiana is next good morning on the
Republican line good morning I am so
happy to hear you I'm a Republican who
is ashamed of the hypocrites in my party
my son is in prison right now he's been
for five years and he's 25 years old and
he didn't do anything worse than what
our president did and our president was
allowed to grow up and become
pretty much of a good person don't you
think a lot of nice people do drugs just
like the sheriff said no Jerry Lewis was
addicted to drugs for 20 years and then
he was able to stop the doctors had
started John Hopkins a hospital where
heroin addicts if they were great
doctors but my son's going to have a
felony background his whole life he's
changed you put these people through
this hate machine called the prison they
don't come out the same but they're
going to come out and they're going to
see your children and you and live in
our society and yet we for nothing more
than what our president did we're
sending less fortunate I didn't have the
money in background that certainly
President Bush's family did my son that
in prison five years he's 25 years old
he'll get out this year I think that is
just I think with that first man's your
first caller said about this just being
an atrocity a Candace slavery is so
right and I love to hear law enforcement
like the sheriff talk about it I I've
over the years talked to different law
enforcement who will covertly agree with
me but they would never speak out this
man is very brave well um it's
interesting that how many of my
colleagues have come to me and said
Billy I agree with you there was ninety
percent of what you're saying in your
book and so that there is a large law
enforcement group out there and it's
mainly the officers who work day and day
out on the streets not necessarily the
political hacks but the people are out
there really doing the job that are
saying this isn't working and that they
don't like the hit the hypocrisy in the
law and they don't like being a part of
that particular kind of system so the
men and women of law enforcement they're
really out there doing the job do agree
but they also say just like the caller
mentioned that they can't come out out
of the closet so to speak and come out
and say gee I i we need change because
they're fearful of either their jobs or
what the community is going to think
some of my fellow sheriff say boy I
sheriff you're absolutely right but I
can't say that I'm not going to get
reelected and but the last time that I
ran I got eighty percent of the vote so
I think people appreciate some straight
talk on this issue and
understanding that there has to be some
change also once again to go back to the
disparity of the way the laws applied
the collar is absolutely right i mean
i'm sure that if our president happened
to use an illegal drug when he was
younger and was was arrested for that it
would have ruined his political career
and we would have missed that
opportunity to have a president like him
in office and i think that would be a
terrible miss case of a misuse of the
criminal justice system good morning to
fuquay varina north carolina good
morning good morning it's fuquay but
that's okay i'm sorry we had a different
pronuncia head i have a couple comments
i'd like to make it seems to me that the
rich get off much easier then the poor
for their first offense you see Darryl
Strawberry you see several of these
other people who get off with nothing
yet you get just a regular guy and he
gets the maximum minimum sentence I
think I also have a feeling with doctors
they're afraid to prescribe medicine
because of the DEA they're afraid to
prescribe and the medicines that that
people actually do need for chronic pain
and stuff like that the DEA have to have
gotten them so afraid that they will not
prescribe and so that person in pain may
go elsewhere to get their medication
have you seen that yeah that's
absolutely right in once again depends
upon your class if you if you got the
access to doctors and psychologists
they'll give you the certain pills that
you might need but if you're if you're
poor then you end up going to the street
dealer for it for those same type of
drugs and then and that's that's that's
really wrong it shouldn't happen that
way and doctors should have the freedom
to to prescribe the drugs that they seem
necessary it's it's not an issue between
the patient and their congressman or the
patient and the police it's a issue
between the patient and the doctor and
the doctor should have the right to
prescribe as he sees necessary from the
Democrat from the Democrats line elkhart
indiana good morning morning i have a
question well actually i'm concerned as
well as the other callers about these
people that are convicted of
a small crime I would call it a
misdemeanor actually when they have a
small amount of pot on them and they are
not convicted of a violent crime and
they're put into the prison and I would
like to know if this can be checked
where are the census taken are the
people that are in prison counted in
that County when the census comes so
that our representatives are overloaded
in prison areas but I don't know about
that it's an interesting thought I never
I never I never thought of that is does
that affect the allocation of
representation I don't know how that
works Ashley Indiana Republican line
good morning with bill masters hi good
morning thank you for c-span good
morning miss masters how are you today
good morning how about yourself sir fine
I'm sitting here biting my fingernails
Chris I want to know if these people
want some wine with their cheese with
that whine to me it's all comes down to
self-controlled and every action you do
has a reaction what we have to do in
this country is we have to if in fact
declare war on drugs then in Afghanistan
we should take our military with napalm
bomb oil if feels go out and attack any
of the countries that are producing the
drugs that are infecting our children
but then in the bottom line it all comes
down to your own actions if I go out and
I know pot is illegal and I smoke
marijuana I have to accept the
consequences of jail time we have to
decide whether we're really going to
have a war and we're going to have a
policy of punishment in China they take
thousands of Chinese people that are
convicted of drug sales and they take
them and execute them we have to wonder
if we have the fortitude to do something
about it or is it just a way to keep
busy buddies and make money for people
such as the DEA and Drug Enforcement the
poor police officers are trying to do
their job if they haven't read their
remand to rights or they haven't done a
certain policy here a drug dealer can
get away with it free and one of the
quotas made a good point earlier saying
that if you have money you're getting
off early and that sends a bed uh
indicator to the people saying well the
rich get away with in the portal which
are some of the conclusions in your book
absolutely and
I don't our country is never going to
execute people we shouldn't execute
people for for for drug use I think
that's just a that's that's not going to
happen here and then just shouldn't
happen and if we bombed all the all the
all the opium fields in the world and
eliminate all the marijuana and
eliminate all the alcohol there'd still
be a certain number people wanted two
percent of the population that would go
and take the gas caps off of cars and
Huff gasoline it is you can't stop the
supply you have to address the demand
people are clever they're smart they're
going to be able to get through whatever
system we develop to to get their drugs
that they need that they want it we're
short on time but just to go back to the
earlier point you're saying that if
drugs are legal then what happens well
you know did to say that we're going to
have a great peaceful society and
there's not going to be any problems
after after prohibition I don't think
that's the case we are still going to
have this problem I just suggesting that
we we deal with it in a different manner
that we go about and say this is a
medical problem it's a social problem
it's a spiritual problem that the
criminal justice system has failed
miserably to control and we're going to
continue to fail you know roughly how
much we spend in drug enforcement I
estimated around 50 billion dollars a
year nationwide and that includes the
federal government somewhere around 18
billion dollars and all the local
governments and state county municipal
governments and their prison costs I
would guess it's somewhere around 50 50
billion dollars a year which money can
be spent in so much better places I mean
what would 50 billion dollars do what it
would it find a cure for breast cancer
would it would it secure our borders
wait would it enable us to really track
down the terrorists and keep track these
people this Warren destruction to our
country I think 50 billion dollars go a
long ways for solving some of the
problems that are really worrisome to
the American public hope will Junction
New York good morning morning um yeah I
I agree with your commentator bill
masters thank you for taking my call I
agree with him on several points I just
had me with Governor Pataki's office I
in the state of New York involved with
legislation in fact I actually had
written my own bills trying to get it
enacted this goes to back to
psychotropic medications I think in this
country and I agree with Bill masters on
many points that we are pushing drugs
too soon without the efficacy of
establish us ever being established such
as you know the school's it we send our
children to school but what is happening
in a Norman eight amount of rate is
children or ended up on medication for
the mere fact that they can't sit still
hey I think that's really truly you know
some children need those drugs I don't
think there's any doubt about it but to
say that the numbers that we are giving
drugs to our children it is necessary I
don't believe it is I don't think it is
at all i think it's largely because we
we don't have two parents anymore the
two parents are both have to work for
five months out of the year to pay our
taxes and we can't devote the attention
that we used to be able to do our
children because uh people are working
so much and i think there's a way to
change all that and and part of that is
the libertarian philosophy of less
government not more government fewer
taxes and allowing people to spend more
time with their children we have a new
drug czar Jon Walters who heads up the
agency he used to be a deputy to build
Bennett when he served as the drugs are
in the first Bush administration have
you talked with him have you had any
reaction from his office I haven't any
reaction from from his office the the US
attorney in Colorado suggested recently
that I want to be a critic of the drug
war I should resign and I disagree with
that obviously I think we need to come
out and law enforcement need to stand up
and and and clearly say when something's
not working due to come out and and and
let them let the public know that it's
not working bill master is sheriff from
Colorado and the book is called drug war
addiction thank you for being with us my
pleasure